Men här behöver vi gå åt samma håll, för vi växer snabbt, vi har höga krav på oss själva och på varandra.
Därför är det otroligt viktigt att få in personer som verkligen vill och vill samma sak.
Så det är en sådan lärdom att gå med rätt personer, annars drar prosto.
Make Sweden Stronger Man är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi David Endyn på Horse Online till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena David.
Hej!
Det är podddebut, känner du nerverna?
Känner du liksom piret i magen?
Ja, men lite nervred ändå, det tycker jag.
Det är två lyssnare, det gör ingenting.
Nej, men jag har förberett mig hyfsat tycker jag, och det är ändå ett ämne.
Jag och bolaget är ämnen jag kan relativt bra tycker jag.
Jag brukar säga det när folk säger såhär, ska man vara med i podd?
Ja, det är ju att sitta och prata om sig själv i en timme.
Det är liksom inte så jävla ofta man får göra det, bara sitta och skrita.
Det är väl trevligt.
Ja, absolut.
Ska vi hoppa in bara lite direkt där?
Vi kan väl börja med bolaget för även om du är en trevlig människa så bryr sig folk mest säkert om bolaget.
Vad är Horse Online?
En internationell e-andelsaktör.
Vi jobbar mycket med att modernisera hur hästfolk köper utrustning.
Mycket där skiftet från lokalt, fysisk andel till digitalt.
Det har gått långt i vissa branscher men inte i vår.
Det finns mycket där att göra.
Det är lite min fördom mot hästfolk.
Man går till den butiken där man har varit och man vill känna på, jag vet inte, jag kan inget om hästar, men man vill känna på sina sadlar och sina chabrakor.
Man vill veta vad det är.
Här är en bet, vad heter de som man har i munnen?
Man köper de märkena man känner igen, från dem man känner igen.
Är det så?
Ja, till viss del.
Varumärkesloyalitet för produkterna, det finns ofta.
Man hittar något som man tycker funkar och man fortsätter gärna med det.
Däremot om man tänker lojalitet till vad man handlade, så är det väl ett större skifte.
Där varierar det betydligt större utsträckning.
Det brukar vi återkomma till även om vår bransch är lite längre tillbaka eller inte har kommit lika långt i sin digitala mognad.
Det är samma kund som handlar hälstecken i den lokala butiken.
Han handlar kanske en stor del av det övriga som kläder och allt det här på nätet.
Det är samma person så det handlar mycket om att någonstans visa att det finns en trovärdig aktör att handla på nätet av, även inom det här segmentet.
Det har historiskt sett inte gjorts i samma utsträckning.
Varför har det inte funnits det?
Det är ju väldigt butikbyggd handel kring ridspartsprodukter i Sverige.
Det bygger mycket kring butiker som har så gjort hela tiden.
Vi kommer väl in på det där sen med lite historia eller så.
När vi startade allt som fanns var butiker med en e-handel.
Det är hans ytterst två aktörer som driver e-handel.
Den e-handel som har gått in i ridsparten har byggt mycket på att man testar dropship, testar inte harde lager, inte har någonting i lager, skriver inte att man har det i lager.
Allting sånt där bygger lite misstro mot att du kan få det snabbt.
Att få det snabbt är avgörande, särskilt när vi pratar idrott.
Det finns utrustning som du inte kan fortsätta din idrott om du inte har det.
Är hästprodukter liksom ett brett sortiment?
Köper man olika produkter till olika hästar?
Eller finns det liksom one size fits all?
Jag försöker bara få en förståelse för hur det där funkar.
Nej det är en enorm variation.
Dels i storleken på de minsta små pondisarna, att det är de största hästar och grejer.
Dels så finns det ju en storleksaspekt som varierar väldigt mycket.
Det finns ju också väldigt mycket olika typer av hästar, olika grenar som hoppning, dressyr, fälthävlan, Islands hästar.
Allt det här har ju anpassad utrustning.
Och någonstans, det är väl inte unikt för utsporten, men materialutrustning det är ju någonting som hela tiden utvecklas.
Det finns mer, det finns bättre saker och så.
Även om det fortfarande är ett trend inom utsport och sannolikt kommer att vara, så finns det en stor variation inom de här produktkategorierna.
Det bara känns som att, om det är en sådan bransch, lite som typ reservdelar eller liknande, där det ska passa till respektive modell, då borde liksom digitalhandel ha en jävla fördel och man borde ligga i framkant för att, om du kommer in till en butik så måste du vara helt hopplöst och försöka hålla massa storlekar i lager eller som ska passa varje.
Hur löser butikerna det kontra beställde de hem grejer?
Ja, nu vill jag kanske ingen expert på just hur våra konkurrenter jobbar i respektive...
Hitta på något, trash talkar de.
Nej men jag tänker väl att det borde vara relativt snarlik metodik, lite så här 80-20.
Man vet ju någonstans var man ska börja och bygga utifrån det.
Det är samma sak som när man växer från något väldigt litet, det är något som är betydligt större, att man börjar ju inte med allting, utan man kan ju inte bygga lager på allting, man får ju börja med chan-modeller och bygga det här utifrån.
Jag gissar ju att en butik i stor utsträckning spelar den efterfrågan som finns lokalt.
Där kan det ju sannolikt vara större variationer, eftersom vi har ett nationellt eller internationellt perspektiv.
Fan jag känner redan David att du är för snäll här, jag känner att du är väldigt diplomatisk.
Det kommer bli svårt, mitt mål under den här podden, jag säger det så att alla vet om det, att det inte är Davids film, men mitt mål är att få dig att säga något riktigt drygt om butiksnätverket med hästar här.
Ja det får vi se vad vi slutar med, det är ju podddebut och allt så man vill ju inte...
Man vet det, man vill inte vara före hela.
Kan vi få lite hårda fakta om Horsonline, hur stora är ni, vilka länder finns ni, eller hur många länder finns ni, hur många är ni som jobbar, hur länge har ni funnits?
Vi firade tio år nu i september förra året, om vi börjar med den enklaste, så vi har ändå funnits ett tag även om bolaget har gått igenom ganska många faser under den tiden som man gör när man ska lära sig att vara entreprenör, allt vad det innebär och så vidare.
Vi är väl nu i 16-17 kanske, som jobbar här på Orson Line, och vi omsatte förra året ungefär 67 miljoner.
Vi har passerat hundra i år, vi är på god väg.
Vi kapade väl en 70-75% av den förlusten vi gjorde i 2024-2025.
Så det gick åt klart bretthåll.
Vi är jättestolt över.
Nu under 2016 så ska vi bli lönsamma.
Vad är det som har gjort att ni ska växa så pass?
Det är ett ganska stort kliv att ta från 67 till över 100.
Det kanske låter procentuellt, det låter mycket procentuellt också, men framförallt är det en jävla skillnad i volym.
Vad är det som driver upp det så mycket?
Jag tror att det här är varken förlust eller tillväxttakt eller någonting av det här är en slump.
Det är inte en produktavfansningar, utan det är någonting som har legat i en plan hela tiden.
Vi har haft några år där vi har jobbat väldigt mycket med struktur i olika leder på många olika sätt.
Det är den strukturen, den grunden som gör att vi kan skala fort och som kan betala sig nu på väldigt många planer.
Kan vi inte få följa med lite på resan?
Om vi går tillbaka tio år och så tar vi någonstans resan i de stegen som du tycker är vettiga.
Sen om det handlar om hur många ni var eller vad som har hänt på vägen eller vilka utmaningar när man bytte lager.
Tar de stegen som du tycker har varit spännande och så får vi höra med lite från start, från uppstarten.
Vilka var ni som startade och hur har ni hamnat där ni är idag?
Vi började egentligen redan 2014 med mig och min bror Hampus.
Vi har hängt ihop sen vi var små.
Vi kommer ovanligt bra överens.
Det har alltid varit ett snack om att vi ska ha företag ihop.
Så sedan tog Hampus tag i det egentligen, kläckte en idé.
Nu får vi ta tag i det.
Först hade vi väl ett par mindre rara idéer.
Vilka var de mindre bra?
Jag vill heta dem mindre bra.
Jag vet knappt om jag ska ta med dig poddformat.
Jo, ta med dig poddformat.
Den första var inte så dum egentligen, men väldigt begränsad, det var att sälja såna här uppbälbara läktastolar som fanns på H-show, en sån här jättestor mäss, 80 000 besökare.
Där man sitter på trädbänkar på en arena.
Då skulle vi sälja läktastolar från Kina tänkte vi.
Sen så visste vi inte hur man handlar från Kina eller någonting.
När vi räknade på det så såg vi att vi kan nog inte leva på stolar en vecka om året.
Så den skippade vi.
Jag älskar att ni hade en kund i tanken.
Det är ändå jävligt skönt.
Det är ett jävligt brief window.
En kund en vecka om året.
Det bygger vi våra affärsmodeller på.
Det var fruktansvärt att ni skötte.
Så det var den bra idén.
Vilken var den dåliga idén?
Ja, det kom ju en bättre idé sen då.
Det kan vi ju spoiler här, men det är det tänkte jag att vi har nog alla förstått.
Men den riktigt dåliga idén, det var ju att vi skulle köpa massa billiga spaker från Kina då.
Och vi vattnade inte vad det innebar.
Herregud, vi kunde ingenting om det.
Men sen så tänkte vi, ja men det är väl kul att det blir billiga produkter.
Alla vill göra billiga produkter.
Så fynprodukter.
Vi tänkte att vi skulle ha någon fynhörna.
Och sen så sa vi det på kalmaritiska då och tyckte det var som fyndehörna.
Då tänkte vi att fyndehörnan är ju ett otroligt roligt koncept då.
Jag älskar det.
Så ja, herregud vad vi spann i väg på där.
Vi skulle ha någon hundsträck och allting återigen på bakspå mässan.
Men till mitt förstånd, det här var en väldigt god, kan jag säga.
Sedan så landade det kanske lite mer undersökning och då stannade det någonstans vidare.
Vi skulle göra någonting vi kan, någonting vi tycker är roligt som verkligen brinner för.
Det var ju ridsparten.
Jag och Borsan har en håll på i 20 år med det här och tävlat och tränat och så.
Sen tittade vi lite på marknaden och då såg vi att största e-handeln 2014 omsatt 3 miljoner.
Det var största arena i e-handlaren på svenska marknaden då.
Då kände vi att det är en ineffektiv marknad.
Släpar efter digitalt.
Det är otroligt traditionellt.
Vi kände att där vill vi vara.
Får ni egentligen inte ha någon kunskap av e-handeln så började vi lära oss helt enkelt.
Det var väl det största steget.
Vi har alltid haft det här med oss också som killar i ridsporten.
Det kanske fanns en fem killar i Kalmar län.
Det är otroligt fåt så att hitta ridkläder och allting är helt omöjligt.
Vi kunde köpa det på någon mästa men det fanns ingenting lokalt till killar.
Det slog oss jättetag när vi tittade på detta.
Det är en frustration vi känner över att butikerna då inte kan hålla särskilt brett med en butik som omsätter lokalt 4-5 miljoner.
Det finns en begränsning hur mycket de kan hålla och det drabade oss ganska hårt.
Men framförallt det de kan hålla är ju bara ett fragment av hela det sortiment som finns att tillgå.
Det var utifrån det vi kände att här har vi verkligen en nisch som vi verkligen kan dyka ner i, som engagerar oss och motiverar oss.
Så var det ridkläder för killar i början?
Nej, det finns ju knappt några killar som köper ridkläder.
Det visade sig att killar köper det mest på mässorna också för det är billigt.
Där ligger det en liten hörna någonstans där det rör sig.
Lite generaliserande men vi precis som butikerna då vid det tillfället behöver börja väldigt smått.
Vi var väldigt smått och vi hade inga pengar.
Utan det var snarare visionen, alltså vad vi ska.
Att vi ska kunna erbjuda en helhet och kunna erbjuda betydsstöret så att det inte är betydligt fler som inte är knutet till vad en lokalbutik tar in där och då.
Så vad var det ni började med och vad var det som gjorde att e-handeln tog fart?
Det är ju två helt olika saker.
Det vi började med gjorde att e-handeln inte tog fart.
Det vi märkte framför allt var att det fanns ett otroligt motstånd i leverantörsledet.
Att jobba med e-handel.
E-handel var ingenting man ville veta av.
Utan vi hade de stenorda kraven för att få sälja deras varor.
Det var att vi skulle ha en butik och vi skulle ha ett skyltfönster där man kunde displaya produkter och vi skulle öppet minst fem dagar i veckan.
Det var standardkrav hos alla.
Jag minns den här tiden för vi har ju funnits sedan 2011.
Jag köpte den 2015-2016 men jag jobbade där innan.
När vi importerade grejer från vissa länder och vissa varumärken då fejkade vi att vi hade butik.
Så vi tog kort med att det såg ut som att vi hade en butik och så skickade här i vår butik.
Så fick man ju köpa grejer men fan vad det var en skum tid.
Men det var ju så.
Det var det och då fanns det ju ändå en ganska lång gång med Anders Mognad 2015 i många branscher även om det inte var till närmastevis, var det här i dag.
Här fick vi slita, jag och Hampus vi åkte till Sverige.
Vi liksom körde upp och träffade folk.
Det var vår grej.
Vi tänkte att vi ska passa en...
Är det så svårt och ska vi ha de bästa relationerna med våra leverantörer?
Vi ska verkligen försöka träffa alla övertygars om att vi menar allvar, vi är seriösa, vi kan det här.
Så vi åkte runt och tror vi fick ihop fem, sex leverantörer till slut då, när vi lanserade den 25 september 2015.
Hur var första året?
Första året visade vi att vi hade gått all in på fel produkter.
Vi som tävlingsrättare kom någonstans utifrån vilka varumärken som var populära och vi gick mycket på kläder där i början.
Och det är helt okunskap.
Helt baserat på att man inte visste då, eller vi visste inte då, hur utmanande konfektion är.
Vi la redan då order som är större än vad vi lägger idag på pre-orders och sådär.
Så det satt ju tillbaka och det fick vi leva lite med men ja, det löste samtidigt.
Överlag i början, första två åren, det var ju bara att testa.
Lära sig företagande, alltså alla de stegen.
Vi var ju väldigt gröna men vi var och är otroligt runa.
Relativt intelligenta, lätt lärda för henne att säga ändå.
Så det blir ju någonstans en kompetensmässig snöbollseffekt.
Så man bygger ju lager på lager bara för att intresset finns där.
Ja, och vad var det som började funka sedan då?
Vad hände när ni såg att fan, det kan ju bli business det här?
Det skedde ju väldigt gradvis för oss eftersom att varje nyleverantör någonstans började övertygas.
Men en vändpunkt var väl när vi tog en av de större grossisterna i Sverige på lite bättre varvelräkning.
Vi faktiskt fick dem att samarbeta med oss.
Som historiskt sett inte samarbetar med några i andel, inte vill göra det.
Knapp nu, även om det är lite annat nu då.
Där så tog vi också in en kompis till mig, Timmy, som delägare i bolaget.
Han gick in med en investering på 100.000 då.
För det var kravet.
Skuldstad sen dess.
Nej men det var kravet från en allervansförande att köpa på 100.000.
Och då tänkte vi, men varför fast än?
Då kör vi.
Och så hoppade Timmy ombord, han kommer från ett helt annat perspektiv, men jäkligt strukturerad och kunnig då.
Han kommer lite annat, han är hästarlärgiker, så det sjunger om det, liksom näsblod om man är nära en häst för länge.
Och får svårt att andas, så han har verkligen ett utanför utifrån perspektiv då.
Så det var också en typisk sak med oss i början då, det var första året och vi tänkte, ja men 100.000, det kör vi på.
Vi glömde ju att det var 100x mom, så det var 25.000 kort när det skulle betalas.
Då fick man springa till mamma och pappa och be om ett lån, så att det löstes.
Mycket sådana där grejer som är ganska roligt nu.
Ja, been there done that.
Det var en tydlig väg, vändpunkt på oss, vi blev en till.
Vi skötte ju allt det här vid sidan av på kvällar och helger.
Så vi blev en till, någon som kunde tillföra ytterligare en aspekt.
När kunde ni börja jobba fulltid i bolaget, hur lång tid tog det, minns du det?
Ja, Hampus var först in, det var hela tiden planen.
Hampus är just nu lagchef, då hade han lite annat också, då var han vd också.
Han började efter sommaren 2018, sen så jobbade han själv till januari 2020, då började jag, och sen till januari 2021.
Ni har eget lager?
Ja.
Ni säljer till rätt många länder, vi sa inte det i sammanfattning där i början, men hur många länder säljer ni till?
Vi säljer till hela Europa nu.
Däremot har vi översatta sajter på holländska, svenska, tyska, polska, norska, och sen har vi en funk om på engelska och den svenska.
Men vi går även utanför EU-länderna, vi täcker i Storbritannien, Schweiz och Norge också.
Det är väl Malta och Island vi inte finns på?
Är det inte jävligt mäckigt att lösa detta från egen?
För jag sa det innan vi började prata här, att det är lite skönt att snacka med ett bolag som inte bara säljer saker som kan skickas i ett kuvert, utan som är lite mäckigt.
Ni har dessutom problematiken att ni har vissa produkter som är små och vissa produkter som är stora.
Det skapar också en komplexitet.
Hur fan löser ni det på egen logistik?
Ja, räkna mycket.
Kolla paketen, förhandla faktor och talen, hitta alternativa sätt att skicka.
Vissa marknader får vara lite dyrare i början.
Vi kan ta hem det på andra ställen.
Man får hela tiden se till en helhet.
Det är lite som betalmixen i kassan, om du har följt i olika alternativ i rätt olika länder.
Man får ju någonstans titta på helheten.
Men tar ni betalt för, om ni ska skicka ett, vad är era tunga produkter jag försöker kolla?
Riktigt tunga saker så tar vi skrymmande kostnader för.
Och får kunden då betala den riktiga kostnaden?
Om ni ska skicka?
Nej, vi har schablo.
Ofta till kundens fördel.
Men det är mycket dyrare för en kund i England att köpa en i Sverige eller betalar man samma?
Nej, det är dyrare.
Särskilt om ikeoländer är ju svårvärde.
Storbritannien och Schweiz är ju betydligt dyrare, dyrare att skicka till.
Det är ju enormt mycket dyrare.
Så därför tar vi ut en höjd faktavgift.
Sen är det lite landsbyt beroende på vad det kostar för oss.
Vi vill ju hålla det på en jämn nivå helt enkelt.
Kan ni få lönsamhet på en sommar?
Jag vill folk köpa när det är så pass mycket dyrare.
Det är ju ett jävla meck, men det måste påverka frakter rätt mycket.
Har de en lokal aktör som kan lösa det billigare?
Det beror på vilka delar av sortimentet också.
Sen kan vi leverera jäkligt fort.
Det kanske inte är fraktkostnaden vi behöver spara på.
Vi kanske kan hitta andra sätt att få TB-nivåerna att gå ihop ändå.
Spännande.
Jag tycker bara att det är svårt att skicka stora grejer runtom i Europa och England är ju en svår marknad att sälja till.
Det är ju en stor utmaning och det blir ju någonstans det där att man får börja brett när man lanserar.
Man får ju testa.
Sedan så handlar det om att sitta och vrida på alla de här reglagerna som gör att kalkylen går ihop och blir bra.
Men i början behöver det ju gosta.
I början behöver man vara lite generös.
Vi kan inte gå in som en helt ny butik med avsvärt sämre vk, en lokal alternativ.
Det vi kan erbjuda till exempel är ju kanske en annan varumärkesportfölj.
Och andra fördelar är att vi är väldigt snabba, strukturerade och jobbar med högt förtroende mot våra kunder.
Men när du säger det här med att ni är snabba, är det ett problem i branschen att folk inte är snabba eller?
Ja det är också en ärvproblematik då.
Det har ju funnits, som jag var inne på, många e-handlare som kommit och gått.
Där man, till exempel vi hade en stor aktör när vi var när vi var lite tidigare i vår resa då, som matade upp alla artiklar alla leverantörer hade.
Och sen skrev de skickas inom en till tre dagar i stort sett.
Och i de allmänna villkoren stod det en liten asterikse om vi har det i lagen annars tar det längre tid.
Och det är någonstans, ja.
Sånt har ju verkligen satt i baka förtroendet.
Det har drabbat e-handelsförtroendet i Nord-Utspå i väldigt många år.
Och det gör att vi behöver vara extremt tydliga med att vi har det i lagen.
Skulle vi inte ha det i lagen, då får du självklart fortfarande beställa det, men då ska vi vara väldigt tydliga med hur lång tid det kommer ta.
För det är det där att hålla löftet man ger till kunden, så vinner vi den gång på gång.
Hur ser er produktmix ut?
Är det alltid andra varumärken, eller har ni egna varumärken?
Till största delen är vi en återförsäljare.
Men det är någonting vi jobbar på vid dem.
Till viss del.
Vi kommer alltid vara en återförsäljare, och majoriteten av det vi säljer ska vara den typen av varumärken.
För vi vill ha det som är trendigt, vi vill ha det som är populärt inom vår bransch och så vidare.
Men det finns en betydande del produkter som vi skulle kunna tillföra något genom att producera det själva.
Det låter som att ni har en ganska genomtänkt plan här.
Du pratar hela tiden som att ni har något sorts hemligt dokument som ni utgår ifrån.
Finns det en sån här uppskriven plan?
Ja, både ja och nej.
Den finns väl uppskriven på många ställen skulle jag kunna säga.
Men ja, vi har ett väldigt bra styrelsearbete i grunden, särskilt sen vi tog in investerare då.
Förutom mig, Hampus och Timmi så är det Jörgen Bööd-Møddo som grundade Nordic Nest.
Han är med oss sen, Ola Forss, som hade Patroner.se för väldigt länge sedan.
Han berättade det som var fascinerande när vi började, och han är från den tiden där man marknadsförde e-handel i tidningen.
Men sen dess har han också varit e-handelsbär på Outnourished.
Och diverse otroligt kompetent, precis som Jörgen.
Så utifrån det perspektivet så har vi en väldigt genomtänkt plan.
Är det därför, är det okej att prata om den investeringen och kan du prata lite om styrelsearbete?
Det här ligger ju långt ifrån mig, jag har ju varken folk som investerar eller styrelse.
Ibland upplever jag bara att vi live har företag.
När vi tar beslut så är det mer, ja det låter väl bra.
Det kör vi på.
Vill du berätta om investeringen först?
Varför ville folk hoppa inför detta några år sedan?
Sen 2019 men det började såklart innan dess.
Allting hänger ihop lite med det vi har pratat om.
Vi någonstans såg en eftersatt bransch och vi såg också någonstans ett lite tidig glas där sanden höll på att rinna ut.
Vi såg det som att det finns en klocka på det här.
Just nu finns det en öppning om vi kan växa starkt och på ett bra sätt.
Annars kommer någon annan göra det.
Antingen en annan svensk aktör som får upp ögonen.
Ett par har försökt och misslyckats.
Eller så kommer det en utländsk aktör.
Därför landade vi någonstans i att vi vill gå och investera spåret.
Vi vill få in kapital och kompetens och kunna växa snabbare.
Vi hittade en match med Jörgen Ola.
Hur fick ni in dem så tidigt?
Hur visste de vilka ni var?
På den tiden så...
Timmi jobbade på ett annat jobb som satt väg i väg med Kalmar Science Park som är en företags inkubator.
Han läste ju på roll-upsen utanför och sen gick han in och pratade med dem.
Sen kom vi med det och fick en hjälp och råd av en affärsbeklare som hjälpte oss med de bitar vi saknade.
Det är mycket kring bolagsstyrning och de här bitarna.
Vi har alltid varit väldigt duktiga på struktur.
Det är någonting som har funnits där från väldigt tidigt.
Kanske det första i två åren, men sedan har vi verkligen jobbat med struktur egentligen i alla led.
Ola var väl lite involverad där.
Jörgen träffade vi första gången bara något sånt här möte där han skulle ge oss lite feedback på sajten.
Men det var en tid innan.
De investerade ju därefter när de inte längre var aktiva i Canva Science Park.
Vi gick ut och började leta lite.
Vi hade träffat både Jörgen och Ola och fått väldigt bra intryck av dem.
De hade träffat oss och fått ett bra intryck av oss också.
Vi började prata och såg att det var en match.
De trodde på vår idé och vi trodde att de kunde vara några vi långsiktigt skulle kunna jobba med, som skulle kunna ta det här ett steg längre.
Vad har deras roll varit?
Du Sonja, sitter ni i någon sorts styrelse och så sitter ni och pratar en gång i kvartalet om vad ni ska göra?
Ja, med styrelsearbetet i centralt, jag har alltid varit väldigt intresserad av av bolagsstyrning och formalia och sånt där också.
Fan, det låter jävligt spännande.
Fan, vi är olika sorter som människor.
Formalia, det låter oerhört intressant att plugga.
Ja, nej, det låter skittråkigt men jag älskar när saker bara kuggar i och funkar.
Och när det funkar hela vägen.
Jag gillar när man kan se att det lirar hela vägen från styrelsen ner i organisationen och det här.
Och det kan intressera mig väldigt mycket.
Och det kan ge mig motivation att jobba med de sakerna på många sätt.
Katja, om jag startar någon styrelse, kan jag få ringa dig då och så kan jag bara säga, David, bara löst detta, snälla.
Kan inte du bara ta tag i detta åt mig?
Herregud.
Ja, det kan ta ett stundtal då.
Ja, det är bra, det är bra.
Det är fan.
Det är skönt, då vet jag att jag ska vända mig.
Men vad gör ni på, vill du berätta lite hur er ansett app ser upp?
Jag tycker det är lite intressant, ni ändå, ibland kan jag tycka att när folk kanske omsätter 10-15 miljoner och så säger de att de har en styrelse så blir det såhär, absolut, men skit i det.
Och sen så när de omsätter en miljard så kan jag fatta att det är fullt rimligt men ni är ju i någon sorts intressant uppskalningsprocess här när ni börjar bli liksom, ja men ni börjar få inte bara ett team av människor i företaget utan det börjar bli lite fler team, folk ska ha olika roller, det börjar bli lite spännande.
Kan du ta oss med på liksom hur organisationen jobbar eller jag vet inte hur detaljerad eller inte detaljerad du vill vara, jag tycker bara det är spännande eftersom det är en intressant process som jag tycker man pratar för lite om.
Ja nej men jag tror väl att styrelsearbete det är ju om man ska lyckas väl med investerare så är det ju otroligt viktigt att förväntningarna är detsamma och det är ju egentligen all typ av affärsuppgörelse.
Om man tänker på programvaror man har köpt, marknadsföringspartner som man har jobbat med, går det i stöpet så är det ofta för att man har olika förväntningar och någonstans är det exakt samma sak fast på en helt annan skala när det gäller investerare eftersom man släpper en del av sitt bolag också.
Men det är ju precis samma sak där egentligen att man vill sätta förväntningarna rätt och för oss är det ju viktigt att vi får fortsätta jobba på det vi tror på.
Det vill ju dem också att vi liksom, de investerar ju i oss på grund av att de tror på det vi gör.
Så det vi vill göra är ju tillföra det här extra lagret med all den kunskap och erfarenhet som finns in i bolaget då.
Och att göra det varannan dag, inspringande, det kommer inte att bli strukturerat och konstruktivt utan det kommer, med största sannolikhet, det finns säkert undantag.
Men det är lätt att det blir disruptivt istället.
Och genom att ha ett styrelsemöte där man liksom sätter riktning och där man någonstans stakar ut de stora frågorna och inte in och killar på operativa detaljer, då är de med att påverka bolagsriktning på övergripande.
Vi får all den erfarenheten.
De får den kontrollen som de bör och ska ha.
Och vi kan någonstans utvecklas inom de ramarna.
Vi får liksom utrymme att utvecklas.
Och det tror jag är jätteviktigt.
Och där tillförs styrelsearbetet väldigt mycket i att man har någonstans ett formellt forum där man dokumenterar de här sakerna.
Men det är inte alltid bara, man sätter sig ner, man får en kaka tänker jag, och så lite kaffe, och så sätter man sig ner och säger man vad ska vi göra nästa år?
Vi ska växa.
Och så är det liksom, ja det hade vi redan tänkt göra.
Eller, vad kommer man fram till på de här?
Är det att man sitter och liksom spånar fram och tillbaks?
Hur mycket konkret information får man ut på de här styrelsemetterna?
Det varierar såklart.
Vi träffas en gång i kvartalet, som vi har gjort nu under fem års tid.
Vissa möten får vi ut extremt mycket, men vissa konstaterar vi mer att vi är på rätt spår, och att nyckeltalen som vi följer pekar åt rätt håll.
Så det är olika men det tar ju någonstans jag, som vd tillsammans med Jörgen som är ordförande fram, när vi tar fram agendan, då plockar vi fram vad vi ska ta upp.
Och vi har ju lite stående punkter, som till exempel rapportering, där vi tittar på verksamhetens hobbyer och så vidare.
Så det är en del.
Sen har vi ofta diskussioner och utvecklingspunkter, där vi någonstans, vi har ju en övergripande strategi vart vi ska, men den knyter vi till milstolpa.
Ett exempel till exempel, det var att vi visste att vi ville bli ett internationellt bolag.
Jörgen nådde stora framgångar med det i Nordic Nest eller Design Online som det hette på den tiden.
Det är en väg vi också varit väldigt intresserade av och tyckte var väldigt spännande.
Hur funkar det att jobba på flera marknader än bara Sverige?
Men att bara lansera utomlands, det i sig ger ju ingen framgång, utan vi behöver en plan för det.
Då sätter vi ut någonstans vad vi behövde.
Vi kände att systemstrukturen vi hade var inte bra nog för att kunna skala och hantera flera marknader effektivt.
Då blev vi första milstolpen någonstans att sätta, vi behöver ett nytt affärssystem.
Det är ett exempel då, i styrelsen jobbar vi mot ett långsiktigt mål och definierar vilka milstolpar, hur och vad och så vidare.
Det är operativa frågor som vi driver här då.
Med stöd när vi behöver, för det är de båda extremt generösa med.
Hur det har gått, eller jag vet inte vad du jobbade med innan givetvis, men hur känns det att vara vd?
Hur känns det att ha vuxit in i ledarrollen för bolaget?
Ibland känns det som att när som helst kommer de på mig.
Det är jättespännande och jätteintressant på väldigt många sätt.
Det ställer andra krav.
Helt klart, det är ofta man har den här känslan, vad har jag egentligen gjort idag?
För nu handlar det så mycket om strategi, organisation och uppföljning.
Alla de här bitarna istället för 3-4 år sedan där det bara var operativa milstolpar.
Man kunde checka av exakt de här sakerna, vad har jag gjort, det ser jag här.
Det är lite annorlunda och det kräver mer.
Det är någonting som jag behöver utvecklas, men det är samtidigt väldigt roligt.
Saknar du det konkreta?
Både ja och nej.
Det är klart att det är väldigt tryggt och alla drar sig till trygghet, men jag känner att det är det här som utvecklar mig just nu.
Vad har varit svårast med att jobba som ledare?
Dels att jobba med sin bror.
Det funkar skämt på sidor och ganska bra, men det är ett aspekt till som man måste ta i beaktande.
Hampus har alltid haft mikrokonflikter.
Vi ryker ihop och sen pratar vi väldigt mycket om det igen.
Det låter jättehälsosämt.
Det känns som det ingår i syskon-
skapet på något sätt.
Ja men det gör det och vi kan ibland gå från ett möte och känna jäklar det där skötte vi snyggt.
Det hanterade vi riktigt bra.
Sen kommer Timmy efteråt och säger hörrni det där var inte jättebra hanterat, ni röker ihop totalt och vi känner nej, nej det är det.
Vi hade väl en bra diskussion sådär.
Det är väl en liten sådan parentes men det hanterar man genom en väldigt, väldigt fritiddefinerad ansvarsområde.
Som hanteras till exempel Dom i Bojan i lagerschef och sköter det helt och fullt med det stöd han behöver från de andra ledningen.
Men annars det jag tycker är någonstans är absolut mest utmanande och utvecklande när man växer det är ju att få in fler personer och hantera ett växande team.
Är du lite nervös för nivån som ni är på nu?
Jag tyckte du sa att ni var 16-17 pers.
Alltså någonstans efter typ, vi är till exempel nio och då vet ju alla vad alla är för någon eller vad man ska säga.
Det är ju tillräckligt litet för att det ska vara smidigt.
Men jag har ju lite ångest inför den dagen när vi blir typ 20, för då blir det helt plötsligt fyra grupper eller något liknande, alltså det känns som en jobbigare period.
Tänker du något på hur du ska hålla, ja alla ska vara vänner, det ska inte finnas några blockader mellan avdelningarna, det ska inte finnas.
Ja, jo det är klart det är saker man jobbar med hela tiden, men proaktivt, jag tycker väl en av de absolut roligaste aspekterna i att driva företag är när vi växer och blir fler.
Alltså fler huvud på plats.
Det började väl egentligen redan när Jörgen Ola kom in.
Det är lätt i den fasen att överskatta sin egen kompetens och tänka att det är vi behöver i en investerade pengar.
Det behövs ju för att kunna skala men kompetensen var så långt mycket mer än vad jag trodde.
Det är någonting jag har tagit med mig därefter.
Alltså om vi anställer personer, det mest spännande för mig är det.
Det är inte att titta på CV-et och checka av vad det är vi gör kan de här göra.
Utan det är hela det brädet man får in som jag inte visste att de kunde.
Eller det är de tillför som jag inte har någon aning om.
Det är som att man får en helt ny nivå i bolaget när man hittar de personerna.
Det tycker jag är otroligt spännande.
Har du några knep kring rekrytering eller är det något?
Hur får man in rätt folk?
Det har jag lärt mig att gå på person.
Gå på person och inte kompetens.
Och jag tycker det är otroligt viktigt att alla går åt samma håll.
Säger du det när du sitter i rekryteringsmötet?
Du är inte bra nog för detta men du är verkligen trevlig så du får börja här.
Jag går på person istället.
Nej det finns såklart en balans i det där.
Vissa roller behöver mer bakgrundskunskap.
Men vi skulle aldrig gå på någon superkompetent som vi inte tror och vill samma sak som oss.
Vi har haft otroligt bra människor här.
Alltså jättebra individer men där vi har känt att det går åt olika håll och då funkar det inte och det kommer aldrig att funka.
Hur länge man än försöker dra ut på det och hoppas att det funkar så kommer det inte att funka.
För alla måste vilja åt samma håll.
Det definierar inte de som anställda eller personer, de kan komma jätteväl till rätta på en annan arbetsplats.
Men här behöver vi gå åt samma håll.
För vi växer snabbt och vi har höga krav på oss själva och på varandra.
Det ska vi ha också.
Därför är det otroligt viktigt att få in personer som verkligen vill och vill samma sak.
Så det är en sådan lärdom att gå med rätt personer.
Annars tar det av plåster.
Vad har flaskhalsarna eller de stora knepigheterna på vägen?
Är det personal eller finns det andra grejer som har varit knepigt?
Ja, det är ju många delar så.
Det finns ju alltid flaskhalsar.
Det är ju, Jörgen brukar säga det och driva företag, det är lite som att gå upp för en trappa.
Och varje nytt steg blir det utmanande på sina sätt.
Vissa flaskhalsar kan man förutse, vissa kan man inte.
Så det är absolut som lager.
Lager är ju i sig ett otroligt intressant ämne.
Det tillsammans med inköp, det händer så mycket där och så fort nu.
Och vi är ju på ett sådant trappsteg just nu där vi har leverantörer som inte riktigt kan möta våra behov.
För de har inte tillräckligt stora lager.
Där har vi en sådan flaskhals där vi kanske behöver börja titta ännu längre fram när de börjar lägga produktionsordrar.
Att vi kommittar och säkrar upp mot att vi kan få någonting för det också såklart då.
Som gynnar båda parter då.
Leverantörsamarbetet är otroligt viktigt.
Och det testas ju alla de här trappstegen.
Vad kan man vara kreativt tillsammans?
Jag tror att det där är en rätt underskattad.
Jag sitter själv med inköpen och lite så som du beskriver att när man växer över vissa summor, vi pratade här om 67 miljoner till 100 miljoner, det blir liksom 33 miljoner varor till som ska säljas.
Säg att det är inköp på typ 15 miljoner.
Det kan ju vara svinmycket för de leverantörerna som det läggs ut på.
Att liksom behöva fördubbla leveransen och det blir så väldigt mycket mer helt plötsligt.
Och det är så många fler lastbilar som ska rulla och det är sånt där.
Hur ser er lokal ut?
Är det en lokal ni äger eller hyr och hur mycket kan den växa?
Sitter ni i Kalmar?
Ja, vi sitter i Kalmar.
Vi har ju den otroliga fördelen att Jörgen är fastighetsägare.
Ah, nice.
Ja, och det är väl få förunnat i vår storlek att få vara med när ens lager byggs och har input.
Men det har vi fått ha, vilket vi är otroligt tacksamma för.
Så vi har två tusen kvadrat lager och ungefär 400 kvadrat kontor.
Toppmodernt anpassat för E&L och Jörgen äger dessutom mer mark så vi kan bygga ut på samma ställe om det behövs.
Så vi har fantastiska förutsättningar när det kommer till faciliteter.
En grej som jag skulle vilja snacka om är resultat.
Ni har ju en ganska stadig tillväxt men ni har också haft lite förluster.
Nu låter det som att det är as mycket förluster, men ni har haft lite förluster.
Hur har tanken gått där och tror du att ni bara kan ställa om till plus?
Jag fattar att ni inte bara tänker att ni ska göra det sådär.
Men liksom, om man är van vid att inte gå med plus, är det så lätt att ställa om?
Både ja och nej.
Det är självklart båda delarna.
Det gör sig inte självt om man ska ha en stor respekt för jobbet som krävs.
Men någonstans, och jag återkommer till det, det här är ingen slump.
Det här är ett medvetet val under flera år.
Att vi ska skala snabbt och sen ska vi ställa om och vara lönsamma.
Det här är ingenting som liksom har fått växa fram under vägen utan att när jag har varit uttalat att vi ska gå de här stegen.
Nu är vi i det läget att vi kan fortsätta växa samtidigt som vi vänder till lönsamhet.
För det vi har känt är att det får inte vara att vi stannar vid 22 miljoner och vänder till lönsamhet och sen växer vi 10 procent per år.
Då kommer vi tappa vår edge, vår relevans och den position vi vill ta på marknaden.
Utan vi behöver växa starkt och nu är vi i ett läge där vi kan växa starkt och vända om till lönsamhet då.
Det här året blir det lite proof of concept då, att vi vrider det sista.
Men redan förra året så fick vi ett oerhört kvitto där vi ökade från 42 till 67 miljoner och minskade förlusten med 70 procent ungefär.
Vad var det som gjorde att ni gjorde det då?
Vi byggde på den planen vi hade.
Vi skalade upp egentligen.
Tidigt hade vi tatt vissa kostnader vi behövde för att sätta oss i rätt läge.
Som till exempel skift av affärssystem.
Vi behövde ha det i navet på plats.
Helt och fullt innan vi kunde skala ut på flera marknader.
Vi behövde ta kostnaderna och lansera ett antal marknader och vi behövde också i samband med det ha tillräckligt med folk på plats för att klara det.
Och det spärs ut i tanke på att vi växer.
Okej, det är egentligen de fasta kostnaderna som inte ökar i samma...
Nej men precis, precis.
Så är det.
Och sen när man blir större så kan man omtandla avtal.
Man kan erbjuda större volymer till både expeditörer och betallösningar och allting.
Vad är liksom slut, man kanske inte har något slutmål men vad är den stora målbilden som sitter på spegeln varje morgon när ni vaknar upp?
Ja, det finns ju, vi har ju ett uttalat mål liksom i vår tillväxt då.
Vi ska bli ett riktigt stort internationellt bolag.
Sen finns det väl individuella mål.
Alla alla har ju sina individuella faktorer.
Hampus på lagret vill bara att saker ska komma in i tid.
Det är hans.
En dag ska liksom chefererna komma den tiden de sa att de skulle komma.
Ja, och Timmys leveranser som man har beställt kommer exakt om volymerna på den dagen som han har sagt.
Och inte 16 pall en vecka för tidigt när han har bemanningen kommande vecka.
Jag älskar det.
De ringer alltid fem minuter från lagret säger, är det någon på plats nu?
Nej, klockan är 17.30 på en fredag.
De är på plats på måndag, precis som vi har skrivit och sagt.
Det är svårt att läsa rätt.
Har du några slutetips till?
Då tänker jag inte allmänna tips till er.
Jag tänker, om man nu är i den här fasen, 20-30 miljoner, man kanske är tre-fyra pers i bolaget, och så ska man börja levla upp till den fasen som ni är i nu, när man tar sikte på hundringen, där man börjar bli x antal team.
Vad är de viktigaste grejerna att ha kontroll på eller tänka på i den, när man går från, det är inte hobbyverksamhet längre, utan man försörjer sig på det, men man ska liksom bli ett riktigt bolag.
Lager är ju, alltså respektera den risken det innebär att binda kapital.
För det kan fort gå utför, om man inte kan lossa det i den takten man behöver och vill.
Sen är det såklart tillväxttakten som spelar roll, men ska du växa 50% per år eller 100% per år, det blir väldigt många mer miljoner varje år.
Och du binder väldigt mycket mer lager väldigt mycket fortare.
Du ökar andel av nyheter som också binder lager för alla det svåra som kommer tillbaka och så vidare.
Så verkligen respektera lagret och vad det faktiskt kan innebära.
Och sen ha koll på siffrorna för riktigt.
Vi är ju i en tid nu där det faktiskt går med små medel att ha väldigt bra koll på siffrorna.
Det har hänt mycket sedan vi började.
Och jag vet att när vi började, det vi hade tillgång till då, det var ju tio gånger mer till en tiondel av priset än vad Jörgen hade när han startade Design Online.
Och den utvecklingen kommer ju fortsätta och fortsätter.
Det behöver inte kosta pengar.
Men det finns så många verktyg som är gratis i början.
Men verkligen ha koll på siffrorna.
Finns det några siffror som du tror att folk ofta missar?
Är det någonting som du upplever att ha koll på detta har verkligen lönat sig för oss?
Det är i detaljerna, det är hela tiden.
E-handel är ju tusen veckor som ska bilda en flod.
Det är ju inte ett reglage, utan det är ju att kunna ha en struktur på siffrorna där du kan börja högt upp och sen zooma in som till exempel på fraktkostnader.
Du kan se per land, vad eller per fraktasminativ, vad lägger vi i förhållande till vilka ordrar.
Sedan kan man zooma in på det och kolla vad det är, vad får vi för straffavgifter och vad är det som kostar pengar.
Samma sak med sortimentet.
Att vi hela tiden kan kolla var och röra sig, hur fort och bara röra sig inte.
Testa snabbt, skala det som funkar, kapa det som inte funkar eller i alla fall om prioritera.
Det var väl halvbag svar.
Ja, alltså ibland så är det lite grann så där när man säger att kapa det som inte funkar.
Och så säger folk, vad menar du med det?
Ja, vad är det som inte funkar?
Ja, det här funkar inte.
Ja, kapa det då?
Alltså på något sätt är det ju rimliga råd, rimliga råd.
Ja, men det är som en sortiment till exempel.
Alltså produkter som inte har rörat sig på ett halvår.
Sannolikt om vi inte tillför något nytt, så kommer inte någon att röra sig nästa halvår.
Då är det bättre att göra plats för något annat.
Ja, exakt.
David, jag vill inte uppta mer av din tid.
Stort, stort tack för att du var med.
Vilken, det är inte ofta man, man pratar inte så mycket med Kalmarbor.
Jag är lite rädd för era dialekt, för ni går upp lite på slutet, så jag vet aldrig om ni ställer frågor eller om ni säger, liksom konkreta meningar.
Det är den svåraste kunden att sälja till folk från Kalmar.
För man vet inte om de förväntar sig ett svar, eller om de har pratat klart.
Nej, den får man leva med.
Stort tack för att du var med i alla fall.
Tack så mycket.
Då tänkte jag att fyndhöna är ett otroligt roligt koncept då.
Jag älskar det!
Så det...
Herregud vad vi spann i väg på där vi skulle ha en hundsträck och allting återigen.
Baks på mässan.